foreign
Nick Jonas is burning up for his wife
Priyanka Chopra and her
it's just a special thing the actress
rocked An Elegant satin red gown at the
London premiere for her new series
Citadel
[Music]
you must be like that
kind of I mean the red dress and all I
saw Nick walking by looking Dapper of
course he got the memo too oh yeah Nick
got the memo and he couldn't resist
making a tick tock about it using an
iconic lyric from his band to the Jonas
Brothers fashion
[Music]
thank you
the song The Joe Bros 2008 hit burning
up where Nick famously sings
[Applause]
[Music]
I mean it was a line delivered with a
lot of passion
and I can completely understand why why
does this sound like you're defending
yourself it's so important oh no I'm not
defending I think you know I'm I'm
really proud to have given the world
so much joy
world you're welcome for a red dress and
there'll be plenty more of that in the
future well fast forward 15 years
Priyanka is the lady in red and fans are
so here for the Nostalgia one commented
on Nick's video this is what he meant
when he sang Red Dress while another
writes respectfully as a Jonas Brothers
Stan Nick Jonas won at life and Nick
stays winning my life is very good right
now the Entertainer made the Trek across
the pond to support pre and her new
Prime video series Citadel streaming
April 28th this show has been five years
in the making
over a year and a half
it was a lot and then our seat come
together and this amazing experience and
be here with the entire cast
it's really special really special I
feel like are you getting emotional
of time
it was 21 it was during covid you know
we were all away from our families it
was a tough show you were a spy like me
if you touch me I'm gonna scream catch
I thought you were going to catch it has
he seen the show yet yes he's seen
multiple versions of it but sweetly he's
gonna watch it again I don't think he's
seen it on the big screen though between
the big screen and the red dress safe to
say we've fully slipped into the lava
[Music]
you baby
foreign